er ist unbändig über 3300 meter hoch und
gehört zu den aktivsten vulkanen der
erde fast jedes jahr bricht er einmal
aus hier auf sizilien am stiefel europas
nur manchmal sind tiefe einblicke
möglich weit in die vier haupt krater
des ätna die emissionen sind gewaltig
ein zehntel aller vulkanischen gasen der
erde werden von diesem vulkan in die
atmosphäre geblasen
ein zerstörer und ein schöpfer zugleich
nirgendwo sei der süden italiens
fruchtbarer als hier im schoß von mama
etwa so nennen die sizilianer ihren
vulkan der alles überragt und auch die
kultur befeuerte als gewaltige kulisse
im theater von taormina und die griechen
glaubten gar die einäugigen zyklopen
hätten in seinem inneren die blitz des
zeus geschmiedet
[Musik]
der deutsche vulkanologe doktor boris
schinke erforscht seit rund 20 jahren
die launen dieses vulkans und doch
erlebt auch er vieles immer wieder neu
wenn der händler formen die landschaft
ständig dieser lavastrom her noch vom
halben jahr da konnte man hier früher
überschauen zu dem großen teil was an
der ostseite vom ätna ist jetzt ist er
diese wand dh die änderungen sind
wirklich erstaunlich schnell und
manchmal wirklich dramatisch boris hat
viele gefährliche momente erlebt zuletzt
vor einem jahr
das war der sechzehnter märz und da war
der neue südost kater gerade wieder
aktiv und da kam dieser lavastrom
herunter
der kann dann hier rüber und es lag
schnee
einige meter dick und normalerweise wenn
lava langsam über relativ flaches
gelände fließt wenn schnee ist dann
passiert da nicht viel aber an dem tag
da ist das ein bisschen anders gelaufen
da ist der schnee eingebrochen und dabei
ist die labern viele bruchstücke
zerbrochen auf einmal ganz viele heiße
oberflächen in kontakt mit dem
schmelzenden schnee und das ist dann zu
dampf geworden und dann braucht mehr
platz und schaffte es sich in dem es
dann so einen dampfstrahler gibt der
schoss dann hier raus genau hier und
riss dabei eine ganze menge von blöcken
von der lava red
so wie dieser hier es konnte ein
englisches kamerateam gerade noch war
dieser dampfstrahler hat vielleicht fünf
sekunden gedauert und gesteins regen
zehn oder fünfzehn sekunden ist das eine
ewigkeit wenn etwas passiert ich habe
ein paar leicht verletzt die kamerafrau
zum beispiel die das gefilmt hatte die
hat glühende teile auf den rücken
bekommen die haben ihre jacke durch
brand und ihren verbrennungen am rücken
verursacht
und das ganze ist dann ungeheuer
aufgeblasen worden in den medien weil
viele sagten dann auch das war ein
krater der die explosion verursacht hat
aber der krater war da oben das ist zwei
kilometer von mir da überhaupt keine
schuld daran
danach war der ätna wieder einmal
gesperrt
doch inzwischen kommen die touristen
wieder in strömen aus der ganzen welt
rund eine million sind ist jedes jahr
von hier aus an rifugio sapienza geht es
nur per seilbahn oder per geländewagen
weiter nach oben und ab 2900 metern höhe
nur zu fuß und ausschließlich in
begleitung erfahrener bergführer
das ziel die bock hannover einer der
haupt krater auf rund 3200 metern höhe
alleingänge können lebensgefährlich sein
der grund sind aber weniger die
vulkanischen gefahren bergführer marco
tomasello und seine kollegen haben schon
mehrfach erlebt wie blitzschnell der
aufenthalt hier oben zum verhängnis
werden kann
das wetter hier ist unberechenbar so ein
hoher berg nahe mehr
da kann sich das wetter schnell händler
von einem tag voller sonne mit guter
sicht können wir uns in kurzer zeit im
nebel befinden
für touristen ist es dann schwer sich zu
orientieren doch was wenn es zum
ausbruch kommt
bisher war mama etwa stets so gnädig
rechtzeitig geheime signale zu senden
damit sich die menschen noch in
sicherheit bringen konnten bevor der
vulkan seine infernalischen produktionen
entfesselt
[Musik]
das ing v die staatliche
überwachungszentrale in catania hier
können die zeichen des vulkans gelesen
und interpretiert werden
doktor boris becker ist als vulkanologe
hier angestellt wacht im rund um die uhr
schichtwechsel mit seinen kollegen über
jedes husten des ätna er weiß was es
bedeutet wenn die 150 messstationen
alarm schlagen
diese zacken sind wie eine art
herzschlag des berges ein ständiges
zittern vulkanischer tremor genannt das
wird erzeugt durch das platzen von
blasen gasblasen an der oberfläche
befindet immer und da sehen wir das ist
momentan relativ nach unter dem gipfel
das heißt so circa 400 meter unter dem
höchsten punkt und wir sehen ja auch in
den letzten wochen und im letzten monat
das sind die gelben und grünen punkte da
sehen wir das hat sich schon ganz
ordentlich bewegt man tiefer mal höher
und das ist ganz typisch und die wurden
dann erwarten dass das noch her höher
geht und dann würden wir sagen da konnte
dann tatsächlich ein neuer ausbruch
beginnen
die menschen im osten siziliens haben in
der vergangenheit gelernt mit ihrer mama
etwa zu leben und halten respektvoll
abstand
denn anders als zb am vesuv reicht die
bebauung nicht so dicht an die charta
heran
seit vor 30 jahren große teile des
gebietes um den gipfel zum
naturschutzgebiet erklärt wurden zu
einer einzigartigen vulkanischen welt
es sind die zeugnisse aus der
vergangenheit die belegen was es
bedeutet dem ätna zu nahe zu kommen und
alles zu verlieren
1992 war die ortschaft safa rahner app
näher am osthang des ätna von der
vernichtung bedroht
ein lavastrom war ein tiefe regionen
vorgedrungen hatte langsam aber
unaufhaltsam erste häuser zerstört
[Musik]
weder durch eilig errichtete welle noch
durch den abwurf von betonklötzen gelang
es das heiße gestein auf seinem weg zu
stoppen
[Musik]
unter der bereits erstarrten oberfläche
floss die lava einfach weiter war nicht
von ihrem weg abzubringen
die militär gelang es erst durch
sprengungen
die lava wenigstens umzulenken
[Musik]
im mai 1992 versiegte endlich der strom
der ort sabratha eben er war gerettet
niemand verletzt
der ätna hat seine macht über den
menschen gezeigt
wissenschaftler können nur versuchen das
risiko kalkulierbar zu machen
für boris der sich als vulkanologe damit
beschäftigt hat der feuer riese aber
noch eine ganz andere bedeutung für mich
hier am edt nation eben und auch immer
wieder hier oben zu sein das ist jedes
mal wieder die erfüllung eines
kindheitstraums das heißt als kind da
hörte ich immer wieder von etwa in den
nachrichten und dachte es muss ein ganz
besonderer vulkan sein und das ist auch
und deswegen jedes mal wenn ich hier
oben wenn da denke ich das ist
das ist wahnsinnig dass träumte ich als
kind und jetzt mache ich das und das ist
ja schon ziemliches privileg
[Musik]
stets auf der suche nach der seele des
vulkans dabei soll drohnen technik
helfen
boris und seine kollegen aus dem
institut in catania sind am südring
unterwegs
sie wollen eines der gewaltigen
lavafelder kartieren
denn mama etwas charakter gilt zwar als
gutmütig und weniger exklusiv als andere
vulkane zugleich schleudert sie bei
einem ausbruch aber oft große mengen an
magna aus ihrem inneren
die wissenschaftler wollen vorhersagen
können welchen weg sie als lava an der
oberfläche nimmt bekommen sehr viel
genauere informationen darüber wie viel
hat der vulkan dieses jahr an mag mal
ausgestoßen und das ist im prinzip übung
für ernstfälle denn wenn dann irgendwann
mal aufmachen der bergflanke ist unklar
war was weiß ich auf ortschaften
zufließt da müssen wir das da muss das
alles sehr gut funktionieren weil wir
müssen wirklich ganz genaue
informationen geben in jetzt seit 1981
ergoss sich ein lavastrom aus einer
spalte am nordhang ungewöhnlich weit ins
tal
die bewohner konnten sich gerade noch
retten winzer verloren ihre
existenzgrundlagen
diese erkalteten gesteinsmassen erinnern
bis heute an die katastrophe chiara vigo
hatte als kind erlebt wie die lava ihrer
familie die weinberge raubte
meter für meter und dann etwas
unerwartetes geschah durch diese
plötzliche richtungsänderung des lover
stroms wurde unser alter weinberg auf
den wir gerade stehen verschont und alle
in der nähe liegenden
landwirtschaftlichen gebäude vom ende
des siebten jahrhunderts auch eine
kirche war dabei
deshalb könnte man meinen dass dieser
richtungswechsel an ein kleines wunder
grenzt so war zumindest ein teil des
weinguts gerettet und damit die existenz
von claras familie inzwischen hat sie
gemeinsam mit ihrem mann jan luca das
erbe ihrer eltern genommen
etwa 130 winzer gibt es am ätna der
furchtbar und fruchtbar zugleich sein
kann
der vulkanische boden ist reich an
mineralien und es war er bestens
geeignet für den anbau der eine renault
masca lese traube so ist die sensorische
qualität außergewöhnlich und ermöglicht
ein perfektes reifen der traum
mama ätna haben sie hier vorsichtshalber
aber immer im blick außer sie hüllt sich
wie auch an diesem tag in wolken
von ihrem balkon aus konnten boris und
seine familie schon spektakuläre
ausbrüche verfolgen
aus sicherer entfernung seine frau
kathrin sie ist französin hat immer
wieder auch angst um ihren mann vor
allem seit dem heftigen gesteins regen
im letzten jahr als er mich danach
angerufen hatte habe ich an seine stimme
sofort gemerkt dass etwas schlimmes
passiert war dass etwas nicht in ordnung
ist
mehr musste er dazu gar nicht sagen ich
habe es gleich verstanden
boris ist vorsichtiger geworden
seine leidenschaft für den vulkan bleibt
unzählige momente hat er mit seiner
kamera dokumentiert wie diesen gesteins
regen auf der autobahn
vor 600 tausend jahren entstand dieser
vulkan seitdem bricht er immer wieder
aus wissenschaftler glauben dass sich
der charakter allmählich ändert die
ausbrüche explosiver werden
aber festlegen möchte sich auch boris
nicht ist halt ein vulkan der im prinzip
zu allem fähig ist dh wenn man uns so
fragt gibt es irgendwas was man völlig
ausschließen kann am ätna dann sagen wir
im prinzip ja eigentlich das einzige was
bei ausschließen ist das dann erlischt
und wie so oft verhüllt mama ätna mal
wieder ihr wahres gesicht
[Musik]